hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich einen
super hübsch ist ein superschönes die
airwave für euch und zwar eine roscheba
um den habe ich die letzten jahre immer
mal wieder gemacht wenn sich mann
verlobt wenn niemand heiratet wenn
jemand geburtstag hat pressetag
muttertag jetzt zb zu weihnachten haben
sich immer alles super darüber gefreut
und es kommt sehr gut an
jetzt zeige ich euch alles was ihr dafür
braucht und ich blende euch auch immer
den preis sein damit ihr das so ungefähr
kalkulieren können wir brauchen einen
blumentopf
den habe ich gold angesprüht und zwar
mit goldfire das habe ich aus dem
baumarkt
wichtig ist nur dass wir den 24 stunden
lang trocknen lassen er hat 15
zentimeter länge und ist 14 zentimeter
lang im durchmesser außerdem über einen
rundholz den habe ich schon auf 55
zentimeter gekürzt und er hat 25
zentimeter im durchmesser
wie gesagt ebenfalls gold angesprüht da
machen wir einen styropor wahl der hat
im umfang 7 40 zentimeter findet ihr
neben wasser bleiben ihr könnt euch auch
daran orientieren dass der styropor ball
perfekt auf den topf passt dann sieht es
oft ich meiner meinung nach am besten
aus außerdem brauchen ganz wichtig witz
zement findet ihr natürlich auch jeden
baum ihr selbst empfehlen weil jetzt
bauen dadurch sehr stabil ist dann
brauchen wir noch ganz viele profis
werde ich am ende noch aufschreiben oder
mitteilen wie viele ich benutzt habe wir
brauchen deko steinchen bronze fahren
dann brauchen wir noch zahnstocher für
die roche zum befestigen
außerdem brauchen hier deko band ganz
wichtig ist auch eine heißklebepistole
und zum schluss zum verpacken noch
geschenkpapier durchsichtiges und einmal
diese lichterketten und am besten nimmt
ihr da die batterie betrieben
und außerdem brauchen wir noch
goldfarbene alufolie daraus schneide ich
mir jetzt einen runden kreis aus
mein preis schneide ich jetzt bis zur
hälfte ein paar streifen ein
wichtig ist dass wir sie nicht ganz bis
zur mitte durchschneidet denn sonst
würde euch da ja auseinander fallen dann
markiere ich mir wo ich meinen stab
hinein tun möchte und höhle da ein loch
aus
in das loch gebe ich dann ein paar
spritzer heißkleber und dann kommt da
schon der stapi mal und der wird
innerhalb von ein paar sekunden fest
dann nehme ich mir meine goldfarbene
alufolie und gäbe in die mitte
heißkleber und nun wird der styropor
ball mit der alufolie umwickelt benutzt
immer wieder heiße thema zwischendurch
weil er sehr schnell aushärtet und so
sieht das ganze fürs erste aus im
nächsten schritt nehme ich mir einen
alten eimer und gebe da ein kilogramm
blitz zement hinein
da gebe ich noch 180 milliliter
leitungswasser hinein und verrühren das
ganze mit meinem alten holzlöffel
benutzt einfach irgendwas was ihr da hat
man nicht mehr braucht
und ab jetzt muss alles sehr schnell
gehen wenn ihr alles gute miteinander
vermischt habt dann nehmt ihr euch euren
blumentopf und gibt euren starb in die
mitte am besten nimmt ihr euch auch
jemanden der euch dabei helfen kann
jetzt drückt die den zement ganz fest an
den boden
das ganze trocknet schon nach ein paar
minuten und dann solltet ihr noch mal
rückstände mit einem feuchten küchentuch
wegwischen
danach höre ich mir weitere blitz sind
an und gebe das noch mal in meinen top
und verstreiche dann alles an der
oberfläche schön glatt das grundgerüst
für den roche baum ist somit fertig und
jetzt kommt der spaßige teil nimmt euch
immer einen zahnstocher und stieß damit
die rutsche auf und gibt ihn
anschließend auf den styropor ball
und wenn keine freien stellen mehr zu
sehen sind dann ist dieser teil auch
erledigt und wir können noch den topf
dekoriert gebt mir noch meine deko
steinchen auf den zement in den topf
damit man das unschöne nicht sieht und
dann ist eigentlich der roche baum schon
fertig und ihr könnt noch nach belieben
dekorieren ich wickle das ganze noch in
geschenk folie ein und machen noch ein
goldenes schleifchen drum
meine roche warum das jetzt fertig ich
habe circa eine stunde gebraucht und ich
habe interessante 83 ss verwendet
der baum ist wirklich sehr stabil also
ihr könnt den verschenken der beschenkte
der kann auch die rookies aufessen neue
dran stecken und weiter verschenken
alles wirklich eine super sache
und ja ansonsten habe ich hier noch
einen schönen lichterkette die ich euch
auch sein wollte finde das macht auch
was her und ihr könnt das jetzt passend
zur weihnachtszeit vorbereiten
verschenken und wenn ihr das nachmachen
möchte ich schreibe euch alles was ihr
wissen müssen nochmal in die infobox
schön dass ihr dabei war bis zum
nächsten mal auf geht s kitchen
ihr könnt euch auch daran orientieren
dass der einfach perfekt auf die auf die
wir brauchen einen blumentopf
den hab ich gold an den löwen day und
spätzle mit hallo zusammen
hallo ihr lieben heute habe ich einen
super hübsches sehr schönen großen
gewinn
hast du gesagt noch zum schluss noch
einmal geschenkt wurde
das war okay und kannst du eh pause
machen wir brauchen goldfarbene deko
steinach bronze farben bronze pharmig
der kocher um die uhr stieß dann an den
baum zu baum befestigen scheiße kannst
es nicht